I am at levity  [Music]  [Music]  my name's came on 14 - double  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  and all that playing football I'm  playing against FIFA personal because  the best in the world  I I've got one but I stay his customer  [Music]  I don't know yeah well I'm gonna Troy  yeah do something with football I want  to have a good family it depends on  where they are in the world if it's in  like Africa or Asia they might not have  the things that we have so we should be  grateful for what we do have some of the  biggest problems in the world are  homeless people and poverty because  everyone should have a home and exerting  tui and no one should be starving from  the sheets